all right thank you very much lane and
welcome everyone good to see that
everyone has joined and i'm going to
start sharing my screen
so what i want to do in my part of the
presentation is go over a little bit
what we will cover in each one of these
parts so
already lane mentioned that we will be
talking about
data science we'll be talking about
machine learning and we'll be speaking a
lot more in detail about every aspect of
these things
now the major objective of this data
science program and how it is different
from some of the other programs that
we've been talking about yesterday and
we'll talk about tomorrow is that this
particular
program is designed to give you some
more general skills in addition to your
ability to analyze biomedical data so
what do i mean by that
first of all
data science in itself is very similar
to bioinformatics so you could define
bioinformatics as the intersection of
computational tools and and methods to
organize and manage your data with a
focus on biology whereas data science is
a lot more general so it could be
applied to a lot more different
applications
besides biology itself and so you can
kind of say that
bioinformatics combines a lot of the
same elements but with this unique focus
on biology
at the same time when people hear the
word bioinformatics that tend to think
of very specific applications of
bioinformatics so people would think
about blast and kind of sequence
alignment and things like that however i
want to talk today about how the nature
of sequencing data is changing and a lot
of the ways that we analyze this data is
also changing
bringing to the forefront this need to
have
data wrangling data analysis data
visualization and machine learning
skills in what we are able to do and so
i'll talk a little bit more about what
we will be able to do in the context of
this particular program to help you uh
come kind of get those skills
so the program will combine three
main modules besides some introductory
material these are the three main
modules that you will have to complete
bioml
logic biomlr and biomel python
now bioml simply stands for
you know bio
bio data and ml stands for machine
learning but essentially it will cover
statistical analysis and machine
learning that starts from data
preparation for statistical analysis all
the way to interpretation of what you
have been able to identify using a
variety of analytical methods
so besides these three
modules there are some additional
modules that you can
choose to complete they're not a
requirement so for those of you that
have
less background in biology we recommend
the course called bytes and molecules
kind of talks a lot about how to apply
different types of
methods and bioinformatics to different
domains like
let's say medical
or maybe basic biology it also
introduces a lot of the
terminology that you would have to
know to
orient yourself so if you come from more
of an engineering background maybe
you're not so sure what's the difference
between a gene and a mutation
exon in intron
or maybe sequencing dna as opposed to
rna and and what does that mean in terms
of data uh because a lot of the words um
are used
in the in a different way uh so that's
something that you can clarify in those
introductory uh modules and then um for
some of you that do not have any
background in engineering so you have
not done any coding at all there are
some introductory modules like
introduction to
bioinformatics and r and introduction to
bioinformatics in python so those would
be useful for anyone that comes without
any coding experience
what these modules provide are some
exercises that clarify what is the
problem or why are we doing what we're
doing
how to address this problem from a
coding perspective
how to use existing code and maybe
modify some of the settings and outputs
and then apply them in an effective way
to a data so here you can see an example
from getting started with bioinformatics
r
how to load data how to visualize it
maybe how to read different types of
data maybe tables or sequences and how
to apply some of these commonly used
bioinformatics tools so this is just to
get you started when you move on to the
more advanced courses like biomel and
python for example you can see that they
will use project examples with curated
data sets taken from publications so in
other words a lot of the methods will
try to replicate the analysis done in
that publication
having to code every step of the way
to be able to understand what is the
method what are some of the assumptions
about the data and how can you choose
between the different methods to really
select the one that is most useful in
the context of the research question
posed by these different data sets
now besides that we have this parallel
so the exact same thing that you will
learn in r
you can learn in python
y r and python the primary reason is
because r
has a lot of commonly used packages you
will find typically outputs from
different r packages and publications
a lot of the statistical analysis is
very easy to use with kind of beautiful
visualization right out of the box with
minimal modification so that's why r is
very popular in bioinformatics you have
a whole
series of packages being developed
every day to address new types of data
and new types of analyses
at the same time in python it seems like
some of the things are going to be a
little bit more challenging in terms of
let's say visualization and making these
beautiful figures that you can just take
and use in your publication but a lot of
times once you get into the syntax
python is
tends to be something that people feel
much more comfortable with after they've
kind of overcome this initial stage of
some technical things that you just have
to practice and know so these two
package or these two languages are very
popular and we'll talk a lot about how
to get started how to set up your
environment and eventually how to use
those in the context of a data set that
you choose or you pick for your project
you know just to kind of give you more
in-depth information about how this is
actually going to work so here's an
example from the python
version of the course you can see that
there are several different sections
here you essentially will be able to
learn the code syntax just by reading
about the code it will explain every
single piece of the code what are we
trying to do import packages loading
data removing specific
portions of the data manipulating our
data and then you can practice so
essentially you can
replicate this code run it and test your
results whether your results are correct
or not and so as you saw here in this
little video you essentially run that
piece of code right in the browser and
it will tell you whether your result is
correct
besides that you will then be able to
take this code and modify it so that you
understand how to apply it to different
types of data sets so each exercise is
going to be first to understand the
objectives and strategies
then to learn the syntax or how to code
this in a particular language like
python
then how to test your understanding in
these coding challenges and so for the
coding challenges you will get a link to
a jupyter notebook
that will typically have some initial
code and then once you
uh look through that code you'll give be
given an assignment how to complete it
how to maybe take something that you've
learned in the lesson and apply it and
you know write it out in code and make
sure that that code works so a jupyter
notebook looks like this essentially
it's a
like a google
document in this case this is a google
colab
where you can take each portion of your
code and run it run right in the browser
in this example all of the code is
already written for you but in some
cases you will have to modify or maybe
write full pieces of code yourself and
that way you'll learn
how not to only learn about the syntax
how to also write it all out yourself
so let's talk a little bit about what
the different sections are going to
cover and so this is an overview of all
of the topics that we are going to be
covering in this program so we're going
to divide it into three different parts
the first part is introduction
the second part is methodology how to
understand and apply these methods and
the last section is actually about the
application to particular projects and
so the first session is going to give
you a sense of comics data terminology
and key concepts that you just have to
know to get started the second portion
will tell you about the details of the
methods what's the difference between
different clustering methods or how to
do dimensionality reduction using
different techniques for different types
of data and what are the differences
between statistical analysis methods and
machine learning methods or deep
learning methods and then finally you
will get introduced to a number of
different research publications with
curated data sets and you will see how
this is used in clinical applications in
biomedical research and in different
aspects of what the industry is doing
with clinical trials or with designing
new drugs and things like that
so let's uh talk a little bit more about
the different challenges that you will
should be able to address
once you complete this full program
typically when people think of big data
they think of data that
is intuitive and easy to understand and
in this case especially in the world of
biomedical research typically that is
not true so there are several different
challenges around it first this data is
unintuitive so you really have to have a
lot of additional information to
understand what the data describes and
number two the data is not structured so
as you can imagine
a lot of these data sets that i have
here on the screen come in their
original form in an unstructured way you
cannot just take them and analyze them
so the first challenge that you should
be able to do after this program is to
structure data and prepare it for
analysis
what kinds of data are we going to be
dealing with primarily we're going to be
talking about omics data this includes
phenomics genomics or dna variation
epigenomics like bisulfite sequencing so
dna methylation or chipseek where you're
looking at histone modifications
and transcriptomic data including some
other types of data sets like
metagenomics so all of these datasets
have to be processed to be useful and
we'll briefly touch on how to process
data because essentially sequencing data
looks like this you have short reads
those short reads have to be aligned to
the reference genome and only after they
have been aligned to the right place on
the genome you can actually quantify how
many you have and translate this into
structured data that is quantified so
you actually have numbers associated
with features like genes and samples
that represent some biological
conditions that we can compare and
contrast
to do that you essentially have to know
some of the basic ways that some of
these coding languages deal with data
and the way they they deal with data in
this example we're going to look at
python so in python you have two major
packages that allow you to work with
matrices that essentially represent
numeric data that you can manipulate and
work with and pandas that allows you to
work with data frames and so we will
learn about how to take this kind of
data prepared for analysis
load it into the environment that we're
working in for example r or python and
then that will make it ready to explore
and so once we've loaded the data we
will start looking at data properties so
how can we
estimate different important parameters
like distribution
like for example
different ways of normalizing data to
check that the data is
kind of consistent with our assumptions
about the data and how to essentially
prepare this data for the method that we
will use in the analysis because
in a typical way that method will have
some expectations about the data that
are important to make this analysis
correct and make it interpretable
as a part of that we will talk about
different ways to visualize data an
important part of kind of playing around
with the data is being able to
for example extract different portions
of your data frame combine them together
to find a data set that you need for
example if you're talking about
you know different types of conditions
and those conditions are defined by
different sexes different ages different
disease stages you might want to look at
just some of those and so one way to do
that is you have different types of
categorical data and you want to create
a data frame so that you can analyze
that and that's called crosstabs
the other way is you can compare
categorical groups so for example
different age groups different sexes
different disease types and then you can
create summary of continuous data for
example gene expression to visualize it
and make it
you